tout le monde sait squeeze aux jeunes
aux taureaux a trop original ou pas au
lieu de stosur song of horror ou plutôt
la témoin de son bras pour ans est un
jeu qui est actuellement en kick starter
et qui a l'air hyper intéressant c'est
un jeu d'horreur c'est parti on va jouer
c'est en vue à la troisième personne un
petit peu comme les jeux d'horreur old
school voyez ok c'est parti alors j'ai
aucune idée du but du jeu mais je sais
qu apparemment il ya un an
monsters tajbert mois ses plus beaux
dunks posséder c'est très joli très très
très joli et on peut par exemple un
trajet avec le décor voilà une note de
catherine une note de la femme de la
maison est ce que je peut la lire non
mais c'est easy monga attendait déjà
quand j'ai bien écrit on a du mal à
traduire nouvel écart voilà passé aux
réunions violée on peut noter ici une
petite trace de sang et ouais l'oeil
expert alors première pièce ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'on peut écouter en fait
voilà rien tu assez flippant le plein
d'air avec la porte mon gars je trouve
père qui émaillent des outils dans le
gard yvan sais pas pourquoi il a changé
de jeu maintenant et dans ce jeu-là
auquel voici donc dans la pièce la plus
glauque de la maison on peut le dire une
barre une tête empaillée contrat bien ça
ça fait peur aussi un peu en collier on
peut en parler la marque me rappelle
quelque chose
immonot à alet un truc qui nous
intéresse à regarder qu'est ce que c'est
que cette note
un cadeau que tu ne veux pas tu sais que
tu ne devrais pas l'ouvrir mais tu ne
peux pas résister un ok il y avait du
sang du vrai sang cette fois au moins ça
veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire quoi ça
j'apprécie part je me casse ok ça va
l'aider sérénité par l'expert alors déjà
si le mec fait ça avant de passer dans
la pièce d'après ces kiss & kill kill et
dans un lieu hanté du cul à une petite
pièce sont mon terrain cachot c'est
validé par l'expert une fois de plus
alors avant à faire le tour de la pièce
quand même parce que là où il ya un vase
en t oui monsieur savait pas trop de
sens si j'avais pas d'humour en theolia
vassort la vache tu as et ça fait
bizarre de juin je dors à la troisième
personne comme ça avec une caméra fixe
et terrorisant une figure son visage
l'ombre de quelqu'un qui n'existe pas on
va écouter une route il ya quoi dossier
rien des allumettes et elle m'aide pour
brûler le truc matin krawa d'hôtes la
caisse qu'on a des mégots et surtout de
fumée qu'à moitié vous avez vu c'est pas
des vrais mégots
oh c'est quoi c'est quoi passer si tu
veux te battre
bon voilà on va écouter mais qu est ce
que l autre côté du coup à anan des
chaînes genre à se battre est normal et
je parle pas des chaînes smoker comme le
groupe d'électro des temps l'ambiance
avec une femme tellement nul à laisser
partir à travers ses sept buts en
championnat mais j'espère que sa part
inscrit mars te plaît s'te plaît c'est
bon du coup moi je vais prendre la
petite porte cachot située juste ici on
l'a déjà examiné tout à l'heure un outil
dollars examiner l'expert ne se trompe
jamais vous en faites pas allez on y va
quoi c'est quoi c'est un bureau d'accord
le bureau de squeeze allez on va lui et
cette lumière verte et connerré mon
talent a vu comme ça complètement du
dessus c'est bizarre j'adore dior
allez petite vanne gain de suite pour
détendre l'atmosphère on a trouvé un
mouchoir parce que le saviez vous avant
les gens ne se mouche est pas dans des
mouchoirs en papier mais dans des
mouchoirs en tissu comme celui là voilà
le kitsch est close voilà donc la toto
explications thomas l'option fait c'est
juste un chiffon d'une cuisine au revoir
aux non j'ai pas vérifié ce paraphe
aller à lui qu'est ce qu'on a ici une
clé macha d'accord ok macha bon bah on
retient si on voit macha quelque part on
saura que c'est la clique correspondent
un frigo qu'est ce qui est assez
important de savoir ce qu'ils mangent et
un dessin est ce qu'on vous dira que son
enfant dessine sa tulameen tout de suite
dans un hôpital psychiatrique bah ouais
je me regardera jamais cherché [ __ ] il
hanté du q7 enfants oh là là toujours
des chaînes des bruits de chaînes ou de
mecs qui gratte à la porte c'est bizarre
hein tu peut allumer ou pas oui allez on
allume on sait jamais tu as même quand
j'aime la lumière c'est encore plus
glauque quoi vous préférez lui tête dans
le noir abbas est fermé et ben voilà il
ya le bruit voilà deux mais non ok on
est un lieu où la fausse manip j'étais à
lui bien entendu ouvert la porte
le bas total
daniel did not make it d'accord écoutez
on va essayer de passer quand même le la
démo alors y'a un escalier aussi on n
est pas les voir au d'accord grande
utilité à leone où va cette fois aux
niveaux en mode pas les steaks on est
des ont égaré un bon du coup j'ai rien
du tout mon inventaire génie les
allumettes nigérien a mal géré un prix
on va allumer toutes les lumières de
cette [ __ ] de maison ça servait à rien
c'est juste pour me rassurer ok ok les
mains les mains alors merci les mains
mais j'ai quand même envie d'entrer
c'est une erreur alors quelqu'un ok je
sais qu'on peut le faire on va réessayer
une dernière fois mais je sens qu'on
peut le faire il ya une porte la
regarder j'ai pas vu ça me garde il ya
un max que vaudou d'armoy des lions ce
pas trop ok d'accord donc s'effectueront
n'a jamais exploré ici à temps il n'ya
pas l'esprit c'est dans et la voilà il
faut une clé pour une 7 pour cela ok on
sait maintenant que si cette porte là
maintenant est-ce qu'on va réussir à
retourner dans la cuisine envie à
revenir en vie on va y aller tout
doucement tout en douceur bottes aux
[ __ ] ok donc il faut plus qu'on a
hélas si on va là on est foutu c'est
malsain ce jeu mon gars c'est un truc de
ouf
même là les fenêtres j'ai peur qu'un
vieux slender man derrière quoi du coup
après oui si je passe cette porte à 2
repart de soutien s'est passé lui avait
les mains c'est bon c'est un gentil a
été soigneusement triés mais elle est
couverte de poussière pas peut-être
c'est une blague une blague c'est une
blague c'est une vague faut que j'aille
là bloqué fogel a bloqué eh ben ça tu
rentres pas je bloque la porte à cholet
ce prêt tu fais croire jamais m'avait
c'est super dur d'aller le secours de
daniel la pendue à cause de l'eau ok
dernière et c'est ce que je vous propose
c'est la technique roche
c'est à dire qu'on va immédiatement dans
la cuisine et on revient avec la clé la
pièce vous ouvrir allez allez regarder
on est direct là mon gars on va dire ha
comme son balai c'est qu'on n'a plus de
respect plus de respect pour cet esprit
maléfique
on a la clé allait l'auroch on peut
parler de speed rome et là attention on
ouvre la pièce avec la clé et qu'est-ce
qui se passe contre segura bras aux
quais bas ou la base il ok c'est bon on
avait réussi à ouvrir et la boum on
serait violée dans un coin sombre
non c'est bon là tu obtiens
l'interrupteur la troupe tard il marche
il marche
j'étais sûr qu'il marcherait pas c'est
quoi ce tournoi milk
l'interrupteur allume toutes les
lumières du monde on va mourir
je sais qu'on va mourir mon gars qu'est
ce que c'est que cet endroit une pièce
secrète
allez nous ça c'est parti à des notes
accroché au mur oh [ __ ] à tamanrasset
paraît qu'elle est immense quoi je
pensais que c'est la fin du jeu c'est
écoutant blessé par une canette d'huile
d'accord ajoie il m'aurait fallu les
allumettes pour elle avec [ __ ] ah non
elle et on passe par là on a pu temps
des couteaux pour tous salle de bains
aux frontières ok ok ok élevé baroque ça
commence à bien faire daniela il donne
des frissons ce jeu et voilà les gens
c'est à dire fin de cette vidéo sur la
démo gratuite de song of au wahoo il ya
un hic starter pour le jeu écoutez si ça
vous plaît je vous invite à faire un
petit don parce que c'est prometteur
c'est super prometteur ça change
énormément des jeux d'horreur qu'on fait
d'habitude d'habitude c'est plus du
début à la première personne nous faut
ramasser des pages ou des ou des bidons
c'est byzance les gens dire ben voilà on
avait compris ça fait super plaisir de
jouer à un jeu d'horreur août et en 3ème
personne c'est des caméras fixes où il
ya une bonne ambiance visuelle et sonore
mais c'est pas même la vidéo ça vous a
plu on se tourne très vite dans une
prochaine
portez vous bien chat au monde à bientôt
au pis